Meine Damen und Herren, die Rolling Stones.
Rock-
Roll-Rockmusik muss jede Menge
Energie und
Humor haben. Wir hoffen, die Leute
zum Lächeln zu bringen. Das ist
exklusiv für Stones, Jagger, Keith Richards und Ronnie Wood.
[Musik] [
Applaus]
[Applaus]
Super  Fan Jimmy Fallon Ronny Wood vom
Rolling Stone
Ich habe gesehen,
dass das ist, was wir
der
[Musik] zeigen wollen.
Ich werde nie böse auf mich, ich
habe einfach nur Glück gehabt, und du weißt,
ich hatte nie wirklich Probleme und ähm
mit meinem  Stimme und ähm, ich habe es immer am
Laufen gehalten, weißt du, und ähm, ich hatte ein paar
Gesangsstunden, um mich zusammenzuhalten, und
deshalb übe ich viel, ähm, auch wenn ich nicht
arbeite, es ist wie im Fitnessstudio, also
gehst du ins Fitnessstudio, also habe ich es getan  Um zu singen, gehe ich
ins Fitnessstudio und singe. Es ist langweilig, aber du
weißt, dass es sich lohnt
Sie
müssen also Ihre Hände trainieren und ähm,
ich habe einen großartigen Physiotherapeuten bei mir,
der
weiß, dass wir Boxershorts machen und
den Körper in Bewegung halten, aber es geht wirklich darum,
[Musik] anzupassen und zu akzeptieren,
das scheint
niemand zu tun
Wenn du jung bist, kannst du rauchen und
trinken und noch
singen, mit 20 oder 30 kannst du nicht rauchen und trinken,
es singt immer noch so gut, und wenn du dann
älter wirst, kannst du es nicht mehr, aber wenn du
viele Leute singst, hast du Pech  Ich
weiß, selbst junge Leute bekommen Probleme.
Ich hatte nie wirklich Probleme. Die
Rolling Stones sehen überhaupt nicht wie die
Rolling
Stones aus, ein alter Mann. Das
Thema des Albums sollte „Du wirst
wütend“ sein, denn ich sage, jeder Titel
sollte
wütend sein  Was ist das
denn heute, ähm, hast du
Tag? Ich wäre
wütend, wenn ich noch
bei meinen Eltern wohnen müsste, weil ich nicht
genug Geld habe, um mir
eine Wohnung zu kaufen oder sogar
eine zu mieten, und das ist es  hart und manche Leute
haben ein hartes Leben, weißt du,
in England ist es im Moment
wirtschaftlich gesehen nicht gerade eine tolle Zeit, und
vielen
Menschen geht es nicht mehr so ​​gut wie
vor 40 Jahren [Musik],
glaube ich, privat  Jets zahlen dafür,
dass
wütende Mercedes in
Hollywood
[Musik]
-Fans
wissen, ja, ich meine, es ist so, dass man
es mit einem Sinn für Humor nehmen muss,
natürlich ist es lustig, und dann
schaut man sich die Rolling Stones in verschiedenen
Altern an  Gruppen, von denen Sie wissen, dass einige
von ihnen 20 sind, einige von ihnen 70,
wissen Sie, also denke ich nicht, dass es wirklich wichtig ist,
wenn man es mit einem Sinn für Humor nimmt.
Sie ist nicht so, ähm, ich meine, es ist eine Art
SP, in gewisser Weise  Mit
der
Zeit Schritt halten, gute Zeiten Ich persönlich denke,
es ist ziemlich harmlos. Ich liebe einfach das
Gefühl der Strecke und ähm, das sind
Steine, die Steine ​​der
Diamanten, Sir Paul McCartney, Sir John
Stevie, Wonder
Lady, es war ein Zufall, dass sie dabei war
Studio nebenan und sie kam rein. Ich
dachte, sie wäre nur zu Besuch, und sie
kam rein und sie und sie kamen rein, hörten
ein wenig zu, kamen rein, gingen ins
Studio, setzten sich zu meinen Füßen und
setzten Kopfhörer auf
Normalerweise erwarte ich nicht, dass Leute
wie Stevie Wonder und Lady Gagar
reinkommen, aber ich meine, wir haben in
Los Angeles aufgenommen und äh, und ich schätze, so etwas
passiert, weißt du,
ich glaube, mit dem Gast
[Musik]
ein paar Mal  Synthesizer, wie ist es, mit Lady
Gaga an einem Song oder mit Elton zu arbeiten? John hat
Klavier gespielt, Elton, du, aber ähm, ich habe
ein paar Mal mit ihm gesprochen, ich wusste, dass er
wirklich daran interessiert war, auf dem Album zu spielen, das ich
spielen muss, Ronnie, du  Es hat mich daran
erinnert, dass die
süßen Klänge des
Himmels, über die die Dinge singen, eine
Anspielung auf
sich selbst waren. Ich sagte, okay, das muss
in diesem bestimmten Zeitrahmen gemacht werden. Wir
hatten einen Produzenten  Ja,
es wirklich möglich zu machen, dass man jeden Tag hineingeht und
zwei, drei
Songs singt. Jamaika, New York und Los
Angeles. Keith Richards lebt in Ke
Richards, lebt in Connecticut. MC Jagger,
lebte in Frank und London. Ronwood, der
in London lebte,
ist ein Außenseiter, von dem alles angetrieben wird
MC
[Musik]
Jagger,
ja, Charlies Geist ist immer bei uns.
Charlie hat einmal zu mir gesagt, wenn du jemals
etwas alleine machst, ist Steve Jordan der
Mann dafür, und wenn es mir wieder gut geht,
komme ich zu dir, aber stelle sicher, dass
es Steve ist  Weißt du, und Charlie ist nicht
gesund geworden, aber Steve kennt Charlies
Arbeit schon so lange, dass er genau weiß, wie sehr
ich daran denke, Charlies Sache zu integrieren,
und er hatte immer noch seinen eigenen Touch.
Weißt du, ich war mit der
Rhythmus-Sektion bei diesem Zeug wirklich zufrieden  Mit anderen
Worten, es ist wirklich so, als würde man
hier in der
Realität den Schläger weitergeben. Ich denke, Charlie, das Interesse
an ihm, trifft
bei vielen
Leuten den Nerv der Zeit. Rolling
[Musik]
Stones,
Ston. Ja, ich erinnere mich an die
Pressekonferenz von Keith und mir, äh, in
einem persönlichen Gespräch  Denmark Street und wir hatten das
Album und da waren zwei Journalisten, einer
vom Feind und einer vom Melody
Maker. Wir haben ihnen ein Pint Bier gekauft und
gesagt, hier ist unser Album.
Rolling
Stones wegen
[Applaus]
er,
wir hoffen, die Leute zum Lächeln zu bringen, wissen Sie,
wenn wir uns amüsieren, wenn sie
die
Musik hören, gehen Sie und sehen Sie sich die Rolling Stones-
Ringe an,
also können wir hoffentlich nächstes Jahr
damit beginnen, wow, das ist ein Oh  Ja, wir müssen
weitermachen, wir bekommen keine
jüngere Musik vom
Rock'n'Roll. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum
sie
einem einfach eine gute Zeit bieten werden. Rockmusik muss jede
Menge haben  voller Energie und es muss
Humor haben und es muss
Aggressivität haben und und wenn es
diese Zutaten nicht enthält, wird es
langweilig, meine Damen und Herren, das
Rollen, danke, danke